I want to talk briefly about what is tio
does for you I'm not gonna get into the
componentry that make it all possible
but there's three real benefits to Sto
and the first is observability
applications are distributed now they
just are even if you're just running
your application in a single kubernetes
cluster in all likelihood to get more
other your developers to be more
productive you've you've gone to a micro
services architecture and there's
communication between your application
between the services in your application
when there's communication between
services and application it means that
you need to understand that
communication in order to understand
your application in order to understand
why it's performing the way it's
performing in order to make sure that
the traffic is going where you need it
to so so sto offers ways to gather
telemetry to gather logs and to gather
traces from every component of your
application every service so that you
can understand it
second it offers operational agility it
offers without recompiling your
application without changing anything in
your source code the ability to change a
retry policy to change a back off policy
to redirect traffic because it's it's
one of your backends is slow to do a
canary test to make sure that that you
can roll out a new version easily so it
offers that operational agility and the
third benefit is is security the ability
to encrypt all of your traffic and in
transit and the ability to use policy to
control which services can communicate
with other services and one thing that
we'll talk about later but I'd like to
emphasize about is tio is that I
consider is tio very much an ala carte
menu it has a lot of features it has a
lot of components however and however
daunting that may sound at times one
thing I like to emphasize when we talk
about is tio is that it is all a cart
and you can choose that the the things
that you want I talked to many customers
about is tio and I often say there's no
silver bullet there's not one feature
that everybody needs for some people
security all they want is security they
want em TLS they need
encryption between their services they
want authorization policy that's all
they need initio gives them that other
people feel like they're flying blind in
kubernetes and when their app is running
slow they don't know why it's running
slow so that observability is the right
thing and for other people it's that
operational agility it's that they need
to be able to do a canary test in order
to release safely so it is an ala carte
menu and you can use the features that
are important to you and just not use
the other ones we talked a lot about
kubernetes with this teo and we did
start with kubernetes that was always
where we intended to start however it's
not just for kubernetes we do run our
control plane in kubernetes and there's
some things that are nice about it and
and the two things in particular that
were nice about kubernetes well three
things one is kubernetes allowed us to
deploy a sidecar proxy easily and
transparently without engineers having
to redo anything about the way they do
deployment having that sidecar lets us
do all the magic of Sto second
kubernetes offers a service registry so
we know where everything's running and
when something scales up we know that
and we can direct traffic appropriately
and thirdly with that sidecar proxy it
allows us to do the networking we need
to to make sure that all the traffic
into and out of the service goes through
it however those problems are solvable
outside of kubernetes also and we're
working with customers today who are
extending their service meshes by
installing proxies in vm based workloads
and we even have customers who are
looking at how they will do that - even
even more legacy things things that are
running in in mainframes another thing
that service mesh if you look at the
Google Trends graph on service mesh in
his it has certainly gone up a lot in
the last couple years there are a lot of
service meshes are out there all of them
are open source the thing that
distinguishes is geo more than anything
else is that this is the one service
mesh project that a lot of the industry
is getting behind there are other
service meshes each of which is built by
a company we we started this with IBM we
worked very very closely with lyft and
their envoy proxy but Red Hat vmware
cisco and the list goes
and on behind companies who have
realized that just like has happened
with orchestration and kubernetes it
will be better for our users if we can
all work together on one technology and
so this is the service mesh that has the
most companies behind it and has the
most momentum because of that and with
that I'm going to turn it over to Russ
who will tell you a little bit about
auto trader thanks ton so we're based in
the UK with the UK version of auto
trader and we're the UK's largest
automotive marketplace and our goal is
about leading the digital future of that
marketplace with the 16th biggest UK
website and we've got something in the
region of 55 million cross platform
visits and on average we've got probably
around 450 thousand vehicles advertised
on our platform on a Marketplace each
day and as you can see we've got around
four times more Auto sort searches than
Google have on their platform which
secrets that we've been around for about
40 years and we've seen lots of
transformation through there we
successfully migrated all our revenues
from our print business to to digital
back in 2013 where we stopped producing
magazines and Carl and I were chatting
about this yesterday and we feel that
we're almost in the next phase of sort
of migration in terms of becoming more
cloud we've been building out a public
private cloud for probably six or seven
years but we're now in a sort of next
stage of that transformation where we're
starting to take more cloud services we
very values-driven
organization we use a lot of data to
inform our decision making we like
experiment and then failing fast and we
use technology to enable us to do that
and we try and avoid using it because
it's shining cool right and and one
thing I will say is that the
transformation that's happened in in our
industries over the last decade decade
and a half as industry after industry
has been changed by technology we've
seen very
large companies get put out of business
what's interesting about auto trader and
gives you a little insight into how they
they view innovation is that they didn't
get put out of business by someone
coming in and taking your market
digitally they realize what was
happening and with a very innovation
embracing culture have established
themselves as they were a leader then
and they're a leader now so so I'd say
that's to say they're fostering a
culture of innovation and it's really
paying off in fact you might say it's
kept you in business right so so let's
talk about where you were a year or so
ago before you started investigating SEO
and and and what the situation was like
and why you got led into this so first
let's just talk practically how big or
how big is your team how many developers
do you have and how many services do you
have okay so great questions the number
of services that we have like I'm sure a
lot of your organizations is constantly
in flux we have new ones coming online
every day and going away but at any
given point in time it floats between
about 350 and 400 services it's a very
micro service architecture so if you
think about our main website is probably
the easiest way to visualize this path
if you go and search for a car on that
you might hit seven eight maybe nine
different services in the backend so we
have a whole mash of things pieced
together in terms of actual
infrastructure cause a little bit few of
you in here interested in that we we
have two big physical data centers based
every Manchester in the UK on those in
those data centers we have what we
consider our oldest platform to be which
was a VMware stack with servers that
were built using chef and puppet we have
a tool which deploys code onto those
servers but they were along with servers
the next evolution of that platform
sorry was our private cloud which Dan
touched on a minute ago which was
Phoenix based servers so every time we
did a deployment we've got new servers
as well so we you know moving in that
direction that private cloud brings in
some standardization as well one of the
problems that we've got on-premise is
all about all of our machines all of
instances of our applications had two
CPUs and two gigs of RAM regardless of
whether or not they needed it so you
might have like a little node web
service which needs a tenth of that it
was just a standard standard amount of
CPU around the given
in terms of developers we've got around
about 200 you say around about 200
developers but we do have a relatively
centralized infrastructure and
operations team as we you know that I'm
part of which is a grand total of about
20 people so you can see the ratio of
operations support against developers
there yeah that's good so you had
several hundred services a couple
hundred developers in a small
infrastructure and operations team each
10 10 or so each of those great
and you mentioned cloud so you you
essentially built your own private cloud
right yes right and what led you to do
that we've moved over the last six or
seven years from manual deployments into
auto deploy and we wanted to make sure
that as an application was released we
were released in the infrastructure at
the same time so getting more towards
sort of Phoenix at servers car tours on
before and and was it that increased
rate of deployment is that is that what
you wanted more agility yeah absolutely
what we wanted to put the the control
back in the developers hands so that
they're not looking at infrastructure
and operations teams to be able to
deploy their applications we wanted them
to be able to do that themselves smaller
features just you know more frequent
releases that was that was the ambition
so no one has to call Carl and face spin
me up in DM I'm gonna install something
exactly it was a tacit based workflow
exactly okay okay great
and how long did an employment take for
some of the older stuff so on the
virtualization our traditional
virtualization platform it could take a
few hours for the private cloud it was
something like 10 minutes okay
and that was with no manual work okay so
you would undergone a transformation on
your own you had you had seen the need
to do this you know by yourself okay so
now you've got a couple hundred
developers you have 10 people in
operations how did they know what was
going on so the operations team will
pretty much look after all the
monitoring for customer-facing
applications and they're all done the
same but the individual micro services
are all monitored differently and the
teams had different logs so and
rather their own metrics for those and
probably you can expand a little bit
unusual so if you think back to the the
graph that you saw a minute go about our
organization and the transformation is
it's gone on from my magazine business
to a fully digital business what happens
generally within those sorts of growth
is you get just organic growth of
tooling so different teams pop up
different tools they're all trying to
solve similar problems what you end up
with is we've got a lasting stack we've
got graphite we've got refiner
I've got sense ooh-wee you saw the wins
the list goes on because all of these
teams fundamentally what they want to be
able to see is the health of their
application or applications as I said
before seven eight nine services to
service that customers request they
might be monitored in three or four
different ways so if you can think about
the operations teams a problem that
they're getting an alert at 2:00 in the
morning that a customer facing websites
experiencing a high error rate trying to
actually track down the root cause of
that problem it's super difficult so so
different different operational tools
different monitoring tools for different
services yeah they can see the life of
the ops person would be be pretty rough
and what about security a lot of traffic
between these services obviously any any
encryption on that no so actually this
is one one of the main drivers for us to
I know we're gonna touch on it a little
bit but so like a lot of a lot of you
will know we do HTTP to the edge of our
sort of infrastructure but the
communication between the services
internally with inside the same area of
the network effectively it was just HTTP
with authen and off c but it wasn't
encrypted in transit and that was one of
the the things that we really wanted to
tackle as well
what kind of languages were you using so
historically I mean we're typically a
Java shop so we've got a really really
old stuff we've got a mixture we've got
some Python we've got some stuff running
on Windows but I'd probably say 90% Java
on the private cloud which is the sort
of middle evolution of our platform the
one that got the deployment times down
to about ten minutes one of the ways
that we achieved that was enforcing
quite a bit more standardization so the
deployable artifacts for that platform
was a jar effectively slipped it was
Java or nothing on that platform right
so so developers would check in the code
and you had a pipeline that would take
that code generate a jar spin up a VM
deploy that jar to the VM right yeah
exactly though I wish to check it and
build a jar posted to a service and it
gets published now um was Java right for
all the use cases absolutely not but the
thing that developers will do when
they're faced with a problem are
constraint and they will work around it
so what we find was happening was that
people for example they were wanting to
run a simple single page application
that they've written in Express in node
or something like that they would embed
this node service into a Java build
process and into a jar just so that they
could deploy onto the taunts of the
platform because they want the benefits
of the platform they want the
standardization and they want the quick
deployment times the fact that they have
to use Java for them was it was a
constrain that was just causing pain so
it's it's the Henry Ford rule any any
language you want as long as it's Java
okay you already hinted at this but
you've got this you've already made some
great strides why did you start using
this to you what made you want to do
this or him want to do this who's
responsible for this so we had a
customer requirement for a new service
that they we were tend to him for and
they asked us to provide end-to-end
encryption and we tried to build it into
our new platform and we we started a
two-week spike and then after about
several months worth of effort
this guy gets super frustrated Anita
said I didn't offer this I think I can
do this a different way can I try
running it with sto said ok and in two
or three days later I think you'd spun
something up and was able to demonstrate
just how easy it was to do then
end-to-end encryption using Sto rather
than trying to build in the sidecar
proxy with our other platform in your
city's fund something up
where was that I just want to before I
answer that question early what we're
what we're actually doing is running two
parallel streams of work so as ruff said
we were trying to implement a cycle
model onto our existing platform so when
you've got a standardized delivery
platform
which is that middle one with the single
jar it's easier to add something to that
and when I say easier though it still
became a several months process and we
still weren't successfully rolling it
out that all the platform which was you
know whole bunch of stuff on windows etc
we just couldn't we couldn't even do it
there so it's what to call out that pain
so even though I couldn't see a light at
the end of the tunnel and that worried
me which is kind of why we stopped we
started looking sto but I wanted to
prove out that sto was gonna give us
what we needed to do quickly I wanted to
spike it effectively the quickest way
for us to do that at the time because we
were involved in this do it I think is I
naught by 2 or something like that back
in the day it was to do it on kubernetes
we didn't have kubernetes on-premise so
the quickest way for me to spin up
kubernetes without meant to worry about
managing this stuff was on GK so that
that's how we managed to basically test
out improve mutual TLS honesty Oh on gke
in the space of a week when we've been
battling with a manual implementation
for months okay so to sum up where you
were you had somewhere between three and
four hundred micro services you had a
couple hundred developers ten people in
ops no encryption between services and
you needed encryption all the way you
had wasted some time building em TLS
yourself VM based a couple CPUs to
everything no matter how big it was
using jar for essentially everything so
that's where you were you did a PLC on
each do you found out this can solve
your problem
and what's interesting here is that what
you needed was into MPLS implementing
sto and kubernetes was just the fastest
way to get that to happen and the
fastest way to get kubernetes to happen
was to use gke right okay so let's talk
about now you proved that it happened
let's talk about the decisions you made
from that point you call them up in you
take and Russ I have good news I can get
this to work and I can get it to work
fast you had to make some decisions
which features Adam Adam is tio did you
need so the sto implementation was
driven out of the requirement for him
tell us as we've already said so that
was the first thing we wanted to prove
our which we did very easily it was a
case of you know turning it on we didn't
have to think about it
however what we were also doing because
we were now in GK and we were going to
public cloud we were bundling in not
just applying this do but effectively a
private cloud to public cloud migration
which is that's a lot of change as I
mentioned earlier on we didn't have a
great amount of insight into
applications from an observability
perspective on the current stack and we
had a whole bunch of different tools so
if we're moving things from on-premise
to public cloud and we're implementing
SDO in which they can into containers
how do we know it's even working so that
was where the uniform observability
started to pull in as well we need to be
able to observe these applications and
these collection of services and we
decided to have a like a multi cloud
model as well so some stuff on premise
some stuff in Google we've got stuff in
Amazon we're all over the place we
needed a consistent view to know that as
we move these things we don't break them
so that they were the two real features
for us and the in the advanced
networking wasn't wasn't a driver in
fact I don't think you've implemented
anything really we're not really using
it now it's there in the back of our
minds as a feature that you know we
might do one day but it's it's a great
example of where we just didn't need to
run right that's great fine and so you
moved to containers you said something
earlier the jar was here was your unit
of deployment what's your unit
deployment now a container so as I've
touched on already people were working
around the single jar problem by just
embedding stuff in really crazy ways and
we want to remove that constraint so the
deployable artifacts on earth that like
the latest version of our platform when
I say our platform by the way just so
everyone's clear I mean we've built a
platform as a service like a Heroku
style model on top of GK and ISTE oh and
the public cloud providers etc to give
that developer that standard interface
where you know they can do deployments
really easily so yeah deploy about
artifacts is now a container which is
great because it means we can suddenly
these are Java wraps that are just
running single page Express service can
just be expressed now but we monitor
them black box in exactly the same way
right and of course kind of implicit as
you said you moved you're still running
a cloud it felt like a cloud before
because the developers didn't touch
infrastructure but now it's it's gke
any any notes on running kubernetes did
you really think about installing and
running kubernetes on Prem or or was GK
an obvious choice so we tried to run
other things on Prem and failed and
decided that we'd use cloud services
instead so we had a very brief
conversation I think it lasted about ten
minutes and we decided that we should
just use Google ok it just made absolute
sense to do it so for example you met
and you you would run Hadoop clusters
right we try to do they'll do that or do
you not know
okay so you've realized that some of
these services it's just easier to have
someone else run it for you absolutely
in kubernetes fell in that in that
bucket yeah we don't want the complete
to manage the complexity of upgrades and
sorting all those you know the that
level it just doesn't give any benefit
to us as an organization so would rather
take it as a money service so you're the
engineer you say that's gonna happen
you're the head of infrastructure you
say I believe you do you have to tell
anyone above you say hey by the way as
part of solving this problem for the
customer we're gonna start running
things in the cloud so our strategy has
been to be cloud native and we've not
defined whether it would be private or
public and when we started demonstrating
some of the features and the benefits
that we got from using gke it was really
really easy to sort of justify the
decision as to why we would do that so
there wasn't really a lot of
conversation I think people just
understood the benefits and I saw that
it was the right thing to do so if when
I hear people talk about adopting this
one of the people are concerned a lot
with friction you have 200 developers
kubernetes and factoring issue on top of
that we're talking about a lot of llamó
a lot of C RDS
how much yeah Mel do your developers
have to deal with this is a really
interesting question because it was one
of the the bigger well it could have
been one of the bigger pain points for a
implement in kubernetes and Sto etc for
one service to get deployed onto our
platform as I described it before
there's about 20 different yama files
like i generated so you've got all the
viewcube anis service manifest
deployments
then you've got all your sto components
you've got virtual services destination
rules sidecars we automate DNS and TLS
as well so you've got certificate
certificate requests ingress can ingress
configuration so there's just tons and
tons of them and if you think about
where we were we were in a position
where developers don't think about the
infrastructure they they build a jar and
they want that jar to run on some
infrastructure so we could just not
scale them up within any sort of
reasonable timeframe
on all of these different api is because
that's fundamentally what they are and
some of those api's were under very
rapid change come back I said earlier on
we were involved in history or very very
early doors so we didn't want to push
that onto the teams so your answer was a
lot of llamó but your developers aren't
writing that yet correct so the approach
that we've gone down and I've been
trying to a few other companies who is
doing this at the moment we've
abstracted them from that concern they
just provide us with a single llamo file
which has some key key aspects about
their application so it's like a minimum
amount of instances that they should run
the name of the image that we should be
running some information about their
health checks
we've exposes like affinities if they
want to run their other applications a
bit of metadata about their service
because we have like a service catalog
and stuff and firewall policies so what
do you talk to and what is gonna sorry
what's going to talk to you and what do
you talk to and from that behind the
scenes the the platform that
infrastructure and operations are
responsible for generates and manages
all that other yama and that's what
really well for us so they still have
they interface with this system through
the CI CD pipeline and they have one
config file you generate all the right
kubernetes and STL files I think that's
a that's a really important point so you
had 350 services did you do this one day
did you just throw them all in how was
the how was the progression it just
overnight so we've started
cherry-picking some of the services so
the things that were already on our
private cloud
they'd been built to be cloud native so
we moved some of those applications
across and that gave people the
confidence that it was
work and then in parallel with that we
started moving some of the applications
or trying to move some of the
applications that historically proved
difficult because they didn't conform to
the single jar so we started working on
those in parallel to give to try and
overcome any of the problems that we
might face so you cherry picked you
cherry pick some easy ones but you
cherry pick some thorny ones too yeah
okay that's that's a good strategy it's
just about some things that one actually
if you don't mind so just to give you an
idea about some of the more gnarly stuff
we've got we've got some containers now
that I've run into on that course oh we
had some windows-based applications
before so we take that and use one of
those difficult applications to drive
out capabilities that we wanted to
deliver on the platform and that we
wanted to expose for Misty oh so it was
a really like iterative approach that
difficult applications were driving the
features rather than was trying to build
all the features up front and then
release the platform so the process was
essentially you you did a POC you built
out some infra you did an initial
rollout and yeah and this became an
iterative thing then you rolled out to a
class of applications you found one that
wouldn't fit you would add capabilities
so the implementation is it went to sum
up the implementation you didn't train
your developers on hto in kubernetes you
trained your infrastructure and ops team
right these people do it your
infrastructure team you had to build a
CI CD pipeline that that deployed the
content to gke your ops team now is is
trained on on but I don't think we had a
slide on it but in your new monitoring
infrastructure right yeah so if you
think of it like the way that our ops
team work is they generally respond to
those their first line support in a lot
of ways so it's like an application is
misbehaving our customers got an
impacting scenario so the symptoms that
they see on all of these platforms are
the same you know it's a customer
imparts an event but what we needed to
train them up in is well how do i debug
that in a container world where i might
have a multi-tenant host so we ended up
building tooling I think one of them is
called monkey Nettie's which just runs
on our clusters and generally just
misbehaves and you know triggers of us
and the ops teams pick those things up
and they just get practiced right
you know on applications misbehaving how
do I look at its logs you know but it's
different it's how do I get onto the box
which is the most common question I was
like well there isn't a box per se so
you got to think about those sorts of
things are you running Prometheus yes so
we I can't might prefer how to slide on
standard I can't remember if they do do
we have a fine on that well we can talk
about it we'll skip past we'll make sure
we get to it how far along are you
so yeah this morning
184 applications live out of 350 and we
really only started ramping this up
about six months ago so six to nine
months something like that so we're well
on the way so you're about halfway I'm
doing my math too rough but you're about
halfway there and and how much traffic
is going to those kubernetes based
services when you ask me this question
the other day because obviously we did a
little better prep it's a great question
because I couldn't answer it on the oil
platform and this is the observability
aspect it's like if if you came to me at
SoCal how much how much HTTP traffic
have we done on our private cloud in the
last 24 hours
I'd go not sure I could probably go in
Agra gay or logs from all of the other
all of the applications run in there and
come up with some value it take me ages
but I think I answered this question for
you by looking at the sto statistics in
about 10 seconds so in the last 24 hours
we've done about 18 million HTTP
requests the overall success rate of
those requests was like ninety-nine
point nine nine eight percent at the
time and that failure rate was covered
by retries so there's no client impact
in events so I'm just able to answer
these questions in moments that's great
and security turn it on it just works LF
and everything yeah so a few people who
have been doing this do implementations
some kind of bring in MPLS as a phased
approach you know some people are
already running gke clusters and they're
out in sto and then they're trying to
bring in a bit of an cos we did an TLS
mandated from the officer I do believe I
made things a little bit easier for us
because we weren't having to mix and
match different policies so you run into
strict mode straight mode and I have
what are you doing for authorization we
actually have our own into an
authentication and authorization
services that
but across all of our platforms so we're
not leveraging any of the sto components
there we just continue to use our
existence done okay so we did have a
slide on visibility so tell us a little
bit about so you you're running from
atheist you run one instance of
Prometheus and everybody sends data it
throw a mixer adapter yeah so well we
have we have several instances of
Prometheus but when you think about
applications that are deployed onto the
delivery platform theirs are the ones
that fit the standard model though there
is just one main Prometheus the
interesting thing that we've done there
with Prometheus is we've got all of this
do matrix going into it we've got the
Kuban ities matrix going into it well
we've also standardized other
disciplines within the business such as
database engineers etc there or
something Prometheus metrics in now so
we actually have a single source of
truth for the state of our platform from
a lot of different perspectives so if
you remember the big list of stuff that
I read out before on the new platform
it's just two tools we've built a couple
of additional alerting things on top of
that so we've got like a chat ops
interface so when sto detects like a
higher than normal error rate for an
application over the last 20 minutes
people can own that we look that through
to run books etc so we've got a much
more consolidated view of the world now
has it made the life of the operations
team better are they happier people
they're not here but I'll speak on their
behalf I think they'll be saying
definitely ok it's a great job that's
good to know
and that prometheus is it running in the
same kubernetes cluster it is yeah just
for no real reason though it to be
honest right um
you run one big cluster yes we do
actually that's another interesting
point so I know a lot of people doing
doing smaller clusters so we have one
large cluster per environment so we have
testing dev pre-pro prod everything in
all of those things gets replicated so
you know separately the separate GCP
projects separate BBC separate companies
cluster separate firewall rules
everything so it's all promoted across
so yeah big cluster per environment we
do have some other clusters we have like
CI CD style clusters which can access
all of those environments and we run
Gnostic stock on GK as well that's a
separate cluster but largely yeah ok can
you talk about how big that cluster is
do you know I mean no
I think it was about 400 CPUs 800 gig of
ram per environment at the moment of the
tough matter okay and we talked a little
bit about this before but obviously now
it you can put whatever you want in that
jar the jar is not a jar anymore it's a
container and you can you can fill it
whatever you want do you find people
doing that absolutely so if you think
about the the build time and also the
startup time I don't know how many of
you work with Java in here and it can be
a little bit slower than just a node up
which just has a one module effectively
and then it starts almost
instantaneously so developer developer
teams they are switching out these big
jars where they don't need them anymore
because they get a faster deployment
process they get a quicker start times
we've had a couple of product teams that
I've been able to take advantage of
technologies that they wouldn't have
been able to use before a graph QL for
example it's not written in Java you
know so they can suddenly deploy these
things and get ideas into production and
you know test things out an extremely
low cost right and in fact test things
out that they just couldn't test before
that's fantastic so I just after that we
we were doing a migration a few few
weeks ago and it was for our launch of
our new price packages and partway
through we would communicate to about
500 of our customers that we were doing
this this this change and we hit a
little bug and it was about four o'clock
in the afternoon and I think you talking
about two hours or something to write
and deploy an application to fix that
that meant that we didn't have to go
back and communicate to 500 of our
customers that we were gonna have to
back out a release so it's just these
capabilities just weren't there before
absolutely that's fantastic so so you
talked about visibility into your
service traffic right and and you know
which services are talking to which etc
what that with a request for second is
on any given service but you also have
visibility into resource consumption now
so talk about how that has changed your
your efficiency so as Carl said
everything used to be provisioned with
two CPUs and 2 Giga RAM but now what
we're seeing through the platform is
that we
got greater visibility of how much
resource it's actually needing so weed
migrate applications up exactly as they
were
and then right-size them and in a lot of
instances we were probably reducing it
by about half and increasingly what
we're staying is we probably need about
sixty to seventy percent less resources
in gke that we did on Purim so it's
about point three of a call around a gig
of ram and some of those then will be
changed accordingly okay and when who
makes sure that a given service has the
right amount of resource so the ops team
doing that no so one of the changes that
this platform is actually brought in so
if you remember before they just
published a jar now they're responsible
for the docker file and also that that
manifest file the CPU and RAM there is
admissible by the product teams it
simply checks into that git repo it's
also editable by the the ops engineers
or the infrastructure engineers anybody
can you know check into that repo
efforts if they make that change I think
the key thing to point out is now
everybody has the visibility in order to
make an informed change whereas before
it was a little bit shooting in the dark
so what we're increasingly seeing is
[Music]
operations teams and the development
teams sitting together looking at the
graphs you know looking at the
performance of the application looking
at infrastructure statistics and making
those changes together whereas before it
used to be very over the fence so it's
actually pushing more DevOps model right
and cost so you you're you're renting
space in data center right now you're
you're writing us a check every month
there are all kinds of implications for
cost how does your boss think about that
I guess ultimately what they're looking
for is some confidence that we've got a
plan to move out of our data centers
consolidate our workloads in the cloud
and we've we're being quite aggressive
in that migration so we we have an
ambition to do it in 18 months and then
once we've done that we'll start looking
to reduce our footprint on physical
datacenter you'll start renting like yes
as you can and your what's interesting
here is that driver was not your reason
for doing this right I mean your cost
was not your driver for doing this
you're you're a reason for doing this
was MPLS ultimately
in the end do you think that because of
the reduction of footprint isn't going
to be cheaper
I'm not making any commitments on okay
okay so that's so that's interesting but
the innovation is good right
as things wasn't it was never driven by
cost it still won't be driven like no we
don't think it's going to cost us any
more but what we do know is that it will
give us greater capability than we could
provision within our own data centers so
I mean Carl touched on it before in
terms of operational agility what the
benefits that we get from really gke
just far outweigh doing and trying to do
that on print right I think there's an
interesting point there was violinist if
we had like for like infrastructure like
at the same number of applications and
stuff probably would but because of the
new capabilities that we've got we're
building more apps he's gonna end up
probably costing us a little bit more
but that's because we're delivering more
capabilities so you're also running sto
now in in that cluster right so you're
running mixer pilot you're running a
sidecar do you know how much it's
costing you yeah so I actually
calculated this the other day
it's about CPU and RAM utilization are
not close to bear in mind we are doing
em TLS which is heavyweight everywhere
about 5% of our CPU Ram is used towards
this do control plane because it's an
optics model and we know how much CPU
and RAM costs on Google cloud we've
worked out that it cost was about $4 per
service as in per application per month
to get all of those capabilities of
misti ability that you have it's kind of
incredible that you can you can
calculate Lu and promise okay so so what
do you use when you look at this project
and we'll get into some numbers in a
minute but how do you measure success
how do you know if this if this product
project succeeded it's not reduced cost
obviously M TLS there's one thing but
photo how else are there any metrics you
would use so the frequency deployments
is is a big thing for us making sure
that our development teams can review
release more frequently and more safely
so not having customer impact is
absolutely like the measure subsequently
deployment and and success for those DM
conveniently rest provided me with some
data that we've thrown up here now you
track the number of deployments that you
do yes so we've been tracking this as
you can see back to
22 2011 I think it is so and this is
this shows a journey that we've been on
from manual deployment through to all to
deploy and now as we start moving on to
the on to the new platform so you can
see the carl effect there in there
there's the car hauler you know it is I
mean this is this is a an almost
unbelievable graph but I saw it I saw
the numbers myself so so the the rate at
which your developers can get code into
production and get a new feature out has
increased dramatically yeah and this
year we're predicting also this coming
financial year we were on from April to
March we're predicting that that numbers
gonna hit 30,000 so doubling it again
after quadrupling in the last couple
years how many of those are failing well
you can see the numbers are just going
down here on yeah we've getting more
confidence with that the platform is
capable of supporting more change but
it's not impacting our customers at all
this is not a percentage this is raw
number this is absolutely so as we saw
that present that number those
deployments go way up you've seen the
number of failing deployments is this
increased visibility when to what do you
attribute that so I actually think the
main driver behind this is because it's
so quick to deploy now I mean literally
you can go from a change in speed option
in a couple of minutes people just
releasing more frequently and doing
smaller changes whereas before if it
takes 8 to 3 hours to do a release
they'll just bundle up more and then
those things go wrong more right
basically so when we look on this in a
percentage basis we've gone from 4 out
of every 100 deployments having a
problem to 2 out of every thousand
deployments having a problem it's it's
an impressive it's an impressive thing
that you've done so the status today
you're you're halfway through you've got
about half your services running all of
them with secure traffic you've reduced
the footprint for most of them obviously
you're deploying a lot and very
successfully and you had to roll out a
new we gave you a new feature recently
in 1.1 you had to roll that out how long
did that take so in order to get NAAFI
chart we had to redeploy every
application and I think it took two of
our engineers to implement the feature
and for all
every up about three hours so they
change their CITV pipeline yes we
actually changed the platform because
the platform is deployed in the same way
actually all of the applications so
change the platform implement the new
sto feature behind the abstraction roll
out the applications in order to pull in
that new feature it's very quick yeah so
if you want to get started with sto
obviously it's an open source project
you can go to sto dot IO you can install
it yourself on gke
we do have an automated installer which
will take open source the CEO and plop
that right onto your tie that's my
animation right there plop that on your
gke cluster you can choose whether or
not you want MT LS it will automatically
send your your metrics to stackdriver
you can plug in your own mixer adapters
as well it's a great way to get started
we do have people a lot of people who
are using it now it we not only do the
installation but we will do upgrades for
you as well so when a new gke
version comes out if there's a new
version of Sto we will and we will
automatically upgrade that for you too
it's not necessarily for every
production deployment it does constrain
which which features of Sto you can
change if you need more flexibility than
it gives you it's not hard to install
sto yourself as you learned and of
course with the anthos announcement
yesterday one of the key components in
anthos is is service mesh so we're
working on productized versions of
managed versions of all the services as
well so yes tio will be included or some
brand named version of VHDL will be
included with anthos and as an open
source project you're welcome to join
the community we have community meetings
every two weeks when people come in and
it's largely users not people who are
contributing this to you so I encourage
with that so thank you very much
everyone please do rate thank you to the
crew in the back for your help have a
good conference
[Music]